hey guys how's it going so today we are
here at a very beautiful mansion in
Topanga California I'm actually really
excited today because we get to do
squibs which is like simulated you know
bullet holes people getting shot we get
to blow up a door with a shotgun which
is gonna be awesome we're sending guys
through a glass table I'm super excited
like we have we have so much cool stuff
going on today we have a whole fight
scene with actual factory I'm super
pumped for the inside stuff for the
action we use like a quicker shutter
because you know it's like it's like the
Saving Private Ryan effect right there's
no motion blur if everything everyone's
moving so quickly you don't want you
don't want all that stuff to be blurred
together
you want it to look good you want to see
it so you shoot on a higher shutter
speed so that you can see all the
movement and if you want you can add
motion later in post oh and we're
shooting in 4k today because we can
surrett one of the many benefits of
shooting on a red so today we're using
the a zoom h4n pretty common you know
it's great that this kind of YouTube
stuff is mobile I'm wearing it with like
a zip tie on my neck records to sd card
just pop that right into a laptop
hopefully you press record we have a
really high ceiling in this area and
that means voices are gonna be really
equity and that's great for the fight
scene because that gives it this great
sense of space but for the dialogue I'm
gonna try get as close as I can without
you know running into camera
and just kind of improvised it make it
up as we go yeah well there's a bunch of
things you can try do to control the
echoes and that really depends on how
much time we end up having a craft a lot
of times you can try like like it sound
put up some flags on c-stands
but we have a lot of furniture in here
there's going to be a lot of objects
that take part in the actual fight so
hopefully that will help absorb a lot of
the real nasty reverberations and then
of course you can always fix it and post
those going to be the break away table
we got some tempered glass here it's
gonna go on the top and will we give you
glass breakers look a second before he
hits the table we're gonna hit those
glass shattering push off the room with
different feather hits and rubber glass
hits and we got a spark in there and
some some cotton flying around the room
and for Mickey light that's about it so
I requested more sweat about five times
now that's it a lot of sweat like you're
a shooting of alien porn from the east
glasses are very fragile yeah fly so
we're gonna fill with water
we had a stunt guy like cut his hand and
when I called cut how he was like not
even come on
public oh my god are you serious and uh
yeah sure enough like his handle just
ripped open and when he 20 was removing
his hand like this he could see the
tendons sliding up and down so he's in
the hospital he's in the emergency right
now thank God we have production
insurance
and cutting reset
the poor man stack
we got 20s ones on the inside 20s on the
outside boom just go to the bank and ask
for 20s and ones and get you a little
paper roll this looks like a legit piece
of movie cash
Gracie was taken from there and he just
stands up so we've been here for a total
of 12 hours we just got done with the
last shot we have to send up this poor
woman's room she came into she's like oh
my goodness this room is a mess come
back in five minutes